after six days the senate voted to
acquit former president trump
then citing the january 6 riot at the
capitol
washington correspondent rashaan hudson
has the latest on the trump's
second impeachment trial donald john
trump former president united states
is not guilty as charged the article of
impeachment
former president donald trump's second
impeachment trial ended like the first
one
the senate voted to acquit the former
president of inciting the january 6th
insurrection
at the capitol we won not guilty
trump attorney michael van der veen
argued that the impeachment was
unconstitutional
but lead house impeachment manager jamie
raskin insisted
democrats lost the case but made their
point
trump stormed our house
with the mob he incited and we defended
our house
seven republicans joined democrats and
voted to convict
but the senate fell 10 votes short of
the required two-third vote
senate majority leader chuck schumer
warned republicans
history would judge them harshly the
failure to convict donald trump
will live as a vote of infamy even
republican leader mitch mcconnell who
voted to acquit the former president
defended his vote but would not defend
trump
president trump is still liable for
everything he did while he was in office
mcconnell said trump may be subject to
other criminal or civil actions
as a private citizen shortly after the
acquittal former president trump
issued a statement thanking his
supporters his attorneys
and those senators that acquitted him in
washington rashad hudson